if we apprehend a demand of this kind in
its broader context and view it as it
appears at the stage which
self-conscious spirit is presently
reached it's clear that spirit has now
got beyond the substantial life it
formerly led in the element of thought
that it is beyond the immediacy of faith
beyond the satisfaction and security of
the certainty that consciousness then
had of its reconciliation with the
essential being and of that beings
universal presence both within and
without it is not only gone beyond all
this into the other extreme of an
insubstantial reflection of itself into
itself but also beyond that to spirit
has not only lost its essential life it
is also conscious of this loss and of
the finitude that is its own content
turning away from the empty husks and
confessing that it lies and wickedness
it reveals itself for so doing and now
demands from philosophy not so much
knowledge of what it is as the recovery
through its agency of that lost sense of
solid and substantial being philosophy
is to meet this need not by opening up
the fast locked nature of substance and
raising this up to self-consciousness
not by bringing consciousness out of its
chaos back to an order based on thought
nor to the simplicity of the notion but
rather by running together what thought
has put asunder by suppressing the
differentiations of the notion and
restoring the feeling of essential being
in short by providing edification rather
than insight the beautiful the holy the
eternal religion and love are the bait
required to arouse the desire to bite
not the notion but ecstasy not the cold
march of necessity and the thing itself
but the ferment of enthusiasm these are
supposed to be what sustains and
continually extends the wealth of
so Section seven continues this
discussion in in Section six about
intuition as a possible way to try to to
approach the absolute and it begins by a
little bit of history of ideas that you
might not you know exactly know where to
locate so that's part of what I want to
do from the start he says spirit is gone
past its substantial life in thought and
he talks about a few modes in which this
has taken place and what Hegel is really
talking about here is what's going on in
terms of changing consciousness in
Europe and some of this is economic some
of this is political some of this is
directly within the realm of philosophy
and the development of the sciences
including those that deal with religion
so remember what a substantial life it's
this sort of taken for granted almost
natural attitude where look this is just
the way things are and a lot of things
aren't being examined aren't being
questioned they're there they're being
assumed so some of the ways in which
this was taking place even in the realm
of thought was with what Hegel called
the immediacy of faith if you think
about Christian Europe in this
conception of Christian Europe that
pervaded the Middle Ages there were
plenty of people who didn't believe by
the way all you got to do is read you
know some of the struggles that monks
went through or you know read about but
the crazy stuff that went out among the
laity of that time you realize that that
you know the age of faith is not an age
of universal faith but if you wanted to
begin from that sort of starting point
it was fairly unproblematic as opposed
to you know once the Enlightenment had
been going on for quite a while and the
erosion that took place because of that
Hegel also talks about the satisfaction
and security of concert antifa sness had
so the the thinker at the time
even so you know Descartes or Hobbs
you know boldly driving off on new paths
talking about totally reforming
philosophy from the ground up both of
them by the way talking about doing that
and both of them actually did for the
philosophy that they did they're still
actually marked to a certain extent even
as much as they engage in doubt by a
kind of satisfaction and security of
certainty in in what it is that they're
able to to think out you know many other
people of course are you know not
engaging in decart's hyperbolic doubt
and they get their categories of
thoughts supplied to them and they just
work with those anything yeah these
these these are what these are at this
is what works he also talks about a
reconciliation with essential being at
its presence inside and outside of us
what do we mean by this God in the
Middle Ages humanity perhaps if you
abandon God but you're still an
optimistic person about human nature or
something like that the way a lot of
Enlightenment materialist types were I
suppose even you know the the realm of
The Libertines and pleasure could fit
into this in a certain way well they
tend to be a little bit more morose
hangul will treat them a bit later on so
why bring all this up
because this isn't going to work anymore
I mean you could go back to it if you
want but you're living a pipe dream
Hegel would say the Enlightenment is not
something you can turn back it's
corrosive effect upon human
consciousness is not something that you
cannot do to use it an old expression
you can't unring that Bell so this has
been lost now not totally lost there's
still an Hegel calls the dry husks empty
house he says spirit is not only gone
beyond all this into the other extreme
of an insubstantial reflection to put
that down in substantial reflection of
itself into itself this is something
very very very different I can't stress
that enough in substantial human
consciousness realizes its own lack of
being the center of things that it can't
necessarily rely on its own judgments as
as being what's truly real you know the
cart would fit into this now to a
certain extent in terms of you know what
his doubt does decide would actually fit
into this all these these other
characters who are realizing paschal as
well man is a thinking read reflection
of itself into itself now that when we
see this term reflection we
automatically think of mirrors Hegel
thinks of reflection in two other ways
and so it's important to stress this at
the beginning while we're working on our
main concepts you could think of it in
terms of mirrors you can also think of
it as
active reflection to thinking about
something right which generates
something new in the process and you can
also think of reflection and especially
when it's this reflection of itself into
itself which is already marked by a kind
of reflexivity right itself into itself
it has a kind of movement a movement of
of mine sort of folding back in upon
itself so this is what spirit or human
consciousness is reduced to this is this
is to be quite alienated to experience
this as opposed to being in your
substantial life even if you're in a
crappy position in in the the life world
that you would have it you know all
you're doing is is doing the menial jobs
and being treated as if you're you know
less than than human you still have some
things you can take for granted you
still know where you fit this is
something quite different and higgles
not saying that this doesn't happen
before the Enlightenment but he thinks
that it's not a widespread enough
phenomenon for us to take notice of in
the Enlightenment though it becomes this
is sort of the dark side of the
Enlightenment so he says spirit has lost
its essential life and it's conscious of
this loss it's conscious of the
estrangement between substantial life
the way things used to be for it which
might be experiencing on childhood and
then you grow out of childhood and now
you're this alienated scholar or
government employee and you're you're
thinking to yourself I I don't know what
the hell's going on anymore and I don't
know where I fit in all I know is I
can't go back to that what am I am I
thinking read like like Pascal said am i
sort of a combination of the greatest
misery and also the greatest you know
Heights that are
they're possible I'm a paradox this is
this is a real problem this is something
that one can feel anguish about so he
says turning away from the empty husks
and confessing that it lies in
wickedness this is also where the origin
of a certain kind of conception of evil
comes from that it reveals itself for so
doing and now demands from philosophy so
here's here's what we need to think
about what do we demand from philosophy
what are we looking for philosophy to
give us are we looking for it to be a
self-help book to use the parlance of
our own time are we looking for it to
shoot us off into the absolute to teach
us some some tricks some mindfulness
stuff that will you know zap us right
there and we'll now feel a ok about no
longer being alienated and we'll be back
maybe not in substantial life but
something even better the absolute he
says philosophy is to meet this need
this recovery of through its agency of
the lost sense of solid and substantial
being philosophy is to meet this need
and it can do it in two different ways
one is by conceptual knowledge by the
process that Hegel ISM self outlining in
the phenomenology by the hard work the
patience and labor of the negative to
use a catch phrase that we're going to
come to fairly soon in this this great
work or does it attempt to do so through
through intuition he says by running
together with thought as put asunder by
suppressing the differentiations of the
notion and restoring the feeling of
essential being I don't want to I don't
want to think about this stuff I just
want to I want to feel it I don't want
to be bothered with having to you know
work my way through this stuff that's
not really the right stuff
man you got a you got to have your heart
in the right place that's the sort of
thing that Hegel is criticizing here and
he says you know all sorts of things
work as traps for this this is what he
calls edification what do we want
edification or do we want knowledge from
philosophy what are the traps or the
baits the beautiful the holy the eternal
religion lie I would say in our own day
we can add some other words that are
easier to relate to ourselves
spirituality the New Age mindfulness all
those things for Hegel would be letting
us down because here's the thing when we
ask what do we demand from philosophy
philosophies of human activity we're
really asking what do we do man from
ourselves
do we want to grow do we want to meet
the absolute where it is by way of our
own growth towards it which has to take
place through systematic conceptual
knowledge through development through
philosophy or do we want to try to take
shortcuts and feel like we're actually
connected to the absolute or something
that matters something that puts
everything in perspective something that
makes sense out of this admittedly
crappy position of being that's the
choice that he's outlining there you may
not have noticed that the first time
that you read through this passage but
this is really a crush point this is one
of his main criticisms of the you know
philosophy if you want to call it that
of intuition that it doesn't demand
enough from philosophy and it doesn't
demand enough from
from ourselves
in keeping with this demand is the
strenuous almost overzealous and
frenzied effort to tear men away from
their preoccupations with the sensuous
from their ordinary private affairs and
to direct their gaze to the Stars as if
they had forgotten all about the divine
and we're ready like worms to content
themselves with dirt and water formerly
they had to have an adorned with a vast
wealth of thoughts and imagery the
meaning of all that is hung on the
thread of light by which it was linked
to that heaven instead of dwelling in
this world's presence men looked beyond
it following this thread to an
otherworldly present so to speak the eye
of the Spirit he had to be forcibly
turned and held fast to the things of
this world and it has taken a long time
before the lucidity which only heavenly
things used to have could penetrate the
dullness and confusion in which the
sense of worldly things was enveloped
and so to make attention to the here and
now as such attention to what has been
called experience and interesting and
valid Enterprise now we seem to need
just the opposite sense is no longer
fast rooted in earthly things sense is
so fast rooted in earthly things that it
requires just as much force to raise it
the spirit shows itself is so
impoverished that like a wander in the
desert craving for a mere mouthful of
water
it seems to crave for its refreshment
only the bare feeling of the divine in
general by the little witch now
satisfies spirit we can measure the
extent of its loss
in this next paragraph section eight
Hegel is continuing to explore the
mindset critically he's going to
criticizes the mindset that demands that
the absolute or reality or philosophy
provide itself to the the person in
terms of intuition in terms of something
that would be graspable without having
to put in a lot of time work labor or
perhaps just labor of a certain kind and
there's a lot going on in this section
but I want to just stop and sort of
contextualize it a bit Hegel has been
criticizing this this point of view and
why well because it's prevalent at his
own time some of the the thinkers that
are going to be looked at by English and
American authors as transcendental
philosophy starting with Conte and then
continuing through are really going to
be stressing this this need to appeal to
intuition and as we pointed out before
this is not something radically new
Spinoza himself with his third way of
knowledge Spinoza is really coming into
vogue among authors at this time after
being in disrepute for a while
he isn't emphasizing that and there's
there's other people too you know the
mystic Jakob uma you know I suppose you
could say another mystic Meister Eckhart
as well but you know Nicolas of who'sa
there's many people out there talking
about a higher form of knowledge and the
question is is this going to be
something that can be provided in terms
of something like an intuitive leap away
from the empirical away from the
historical away from the everyday that
we experience is it going to be
something special that takes us into a
starry beyond to use Hegel's phrase or
if we want to have what that's going to
provide to us because Hegel does think
there is something
does it have to kind of integrate itself
with the realm that it seems to want to
leave behind that's the challenge that
Hegel is is posing in this this section
and in in the previous section where he
was criticizing this appeal to intuition
as well so he's framing the way in which
they see things and in this section he's
saying something that to a certain
degree he endorses but to a certain
degree he is presenting merely to sort
of put it out there as a incomplete
position that will be taken up by his
own position so he says in keeping with
this demand what's the demand that that
the absol would be given in terms of
intuition is the strenuous almost
overzealous in frenzied effort determine
away from their preoccupation with the
sensuous Sensibility the ordinary
private affairs and to direct their gaze
to the Stars to something that's higher
something that is more Universal away
from the particular towards the
universal and we have a antithesis being
set up here one that's particularly
acute in modernity after the
Enlightenment during the middle of the
the massive changes that are occurring
within the economy with globalization of
the Lydia knows globalization quite yet
and the Industrial Revolution with new
political forms you know this is soon
after the French Revolution after the
American Revolution after the you know
developments in Britain and there's
interesting things going on in Germany
so there's this there's a lot of ferment
right now and the question is should
people be paying attention to the world
of the experiential the empirical which
is also to a certain extent the the
pride that my experience is my
experience I can only experience my
portion I can read about your experience
but I can't directly experience it
should we focus just
the world or should we look to what
people had focused on before and when
you actually read say ancient history or
medieval history you find that that the
representations that moderns give of it
are usually very one-sided and I won't
say romantic but romanticized and the
way that this views things is you know
this is where people are focused today
this is where they used to be focused
they focus on the divine they focus on
what was beyond the world what was
metaphysical what was eternal that focus
on what he calls beautiful phrase here a
heaven adorned with a vast wealth of
thoughts and imagery so you know for an
example of this think of if you've ever
seen it the there's a beautiful icon in
the the Sloat gallery at Notre Dame
University and there's others I believe
like this and it shows this icon depicts
the orders of the angels in heaven and
so it's depicting heaven as this dynamic
liturgy where all these different things
are going on and they're all
interconnected and human beings
themselves can play some sort of small
role in this where human beings are not
really the center of the let's say the
universe because even the universe isn't
the center of the universe if we mean by
universe that which is most real that
which is ultimately grounding everything
else that which has the highest value
now that would be an example of what
Hegel is calling this heaven adorn ER
the vast wealth of thoughts and imagery
and like he says you know with this
understanding of things people will say
you know ancient wisdom or you know is
becoming quite popular to talk about
medieval times at that time
which you know medieval times if you
actually read the history the letters of
people worried actually quite secular
but there was this conception that
people were more attuned to the
supernatural to to the beyond the
worldly to the transcendent back then
and the real the real task was to get
them to actually pay attention to this
stuff this is a very modern conception
of modernity by the way it's one that
actually doesn't doesn't fit the facts
quite so well and that's perhaps what
Hegel is a little bit loath to endorse
it entirely and he does say that these
these other people are sort of
projecting that as the the Rays own
death for why why their approach is the
right approach so he says the eye of the
spirit had to be forcibly turned and
held fast to the things of this world
that's the the force of secularization
has taken a long time before the
lucidity Jony heavenly things could have
to penetrate the dullness and confusion
which the sense of worldly things was
enveloped in to pay attention to the
here and now and he says this was and
this was you know a sort of progress
because now they're actually paying
attention to and he brings up this this
key word here experience the realm of
experience as opposed to the the
metaphysical the that which is beyond
just mere experience and so there's this
movement away from that towards this and
now what we need is a counter movement
back towards this and so he says now we
seem to need just the opposite sense is
so fast rooted in earthly things it
requires just as much force to raise it
the spirit shows itself so impoverished
and he's got this beautiful metaphor
that like a wanderer out in the desert
who's craving a drink of water because
they're actually you know dying of
thirst
they will take anything that somebody
puts in front of them this is Hegel's
criticism of these these forms of
philosophy or forms of culture that are
making a
appeals to intuition that they're
basically just a cup of water or who
knows what being offered to the thirsty
traveler who is spirit who actually
needs both sides of these spirit has
been lacking this so much in the the
secularized modernizing world that it
will take just about anything that
offers itself as that without without
being critical without actually seeing
whether it really is the divine whether
it really is representing something
metaphysical something transcendent or
not and Hegel sees this is a real
problem so he says by the little which
set now satisfied spirit we can measure
the extent of its loss so we see the
discussion of loss and in strange
material graph seven being used now to
talk about why people are willing to
jump into to take sort of a if we want
to use a Kierkegaard and phrase a leap
of faith into some sort of super
sensible beyond and the last thing to
see about this is that this is really a
problematic that is coming about because
of how not just other thinkers but
especially a manual contest frame things
you know there is a sort of sisian
running through this is the world that
we can actually have knowledge about the
empirical this is what science can
actually deal with this is the realm
metaphysics and theoretical metaphysics
or can't really can't do much of
anything in the practical world while in
the practical side of this rather where
we're dealing with practical reason and
ethics there we can actually we can make
a bit more progress there's a bit more
traction but none of this is strictly
speaking no and there's really no back
and forth between these available after
cut
does his work and so you might say what
Hegel is doing here is he's seeing where
the Conchie and problematic goes to and
then he's going to try to get past it
this modest complacency in receiving or
this Baroness and giving does not
however befits science whoever seeks me
ratification whoever wants to shroud it
and miss the manifold variety of his
earthly existence and a thought in order
to pursue the indeterminate enjoyment of
this indeterminate divinity may look
where he wishes to find all this he will
find ample opportunity to dream up
something for himself but philosophy
must beware of the wish to be edifying
so Hagel concludes this passage by
saying philosophy must beware of the
wish to be edifying and why is it well
is we're going to realize edification
and edifying our dirty words in the
phenomenology they're there what
philosophy often time gets reduced to
and thereby becomes less than philosophy
and Hegel wants to avoid that like the
play another word for edifying would be
up building or you know think about the
the notion that we have that you often
see in a lot of contemporary education
that we're supposed to meet the learner
not only where they are but where
they're comfortable and then you know
try to bring them a little bit closer
and if we can't get them all the way
well that's ok because we made a little
bit of progress
that's what edification means that's one
way to sort of wrap your head around it
and what Hegel is criticizing still in
this passage he's still talking about
these at these views on philosophy that
reduce it to trying to train our
intuition to be able to grasp something
something divine something transcendent
something super sensible and leave
behind the the empirical world the
problem is that gets very very hazy like
you said in the passage just before this
it's like somebody who's so thirsty that
they'll take anything that you offer
them to drink and they'll be satisfied
with it because they're getting
something at least yeah that's what
happens with edification it's a matter
of he talks about complacency I like to
frame this in terms of low expectations
now that's not to say that we
automatically ought to have super high
expectations that can't possibly be meta
philosophy I actually run across this
many times in my videos where viewers
are looking for something to be made
totally clear for them which can't
really be made totally clear for them
because it requires some some
involvement some effort on their parts
and careful reading quite often see this
with a lot of students as well people
want to say what's your definition
of this and you know real philosophy
doesn't proceed by by starting with
definitions and then you know proceeding
deductively you know to to produce
arguments that that's sort of a that's a
story that we tell people about
philosophy that as soon as you start
reading a lot of real philosophy
realized well that was that was a great
oversimplification to use Vidkun Stein's
analogy that's sort of like doing
calculations about how things are going
to go without taking into account air
resistance the air resistance is there
because it's real and there's a lot more
thought resistance than there's air
resistance going back to this so having
low expectations about what philosophy
ought to provide about what it is that
we're trying to do when we're using our
minds because remember philosophy for
Hegel is this this totalizing activity
that has to become completely scientific
completely systematic it is going to
literally encompass everything that's
what I mean by totalizing
it's going to take in the totality and
make it intelligible that's a much
higher expectation then well it'll give
me something I can believe so I can wake
up each day and feel a little bit better
about myself or it'll give me something
that I can chat about with other people
and have some common ground or and we
can pick a number of different lowered
expectations about philosophy in this
case the lower expectation is that well
it'll give me something it's not
something really clear or something that
I can wrap my head around too easily but
something that will like get me on the
path to intuition something that will
sound cool something that will sound
kind of mystical if we want to put it in
contemporary terms and you know that
that's attractive to a lot of people
Hegel thinks that that's on the part of
the person receiving that's a matter of
low expectations the part of the one
giving it's a foremost in genus you're
not actually giving people
enough to go on you're not actually
providing them with something that they
can really sink their teeth into and we
want to continue that metaphor not only
to find some meat but draw some blood
and some sustenance from it so the
giving the receiving the Philosopher's
the the culture that's taking that in
and producing other philosophers in turn
who are also going to be equally stingy
and getting I mean Hegel would not only
be willing to say this about this kind
of fuzzy Dunsey mystical intuition based
philosophy I think he'd be willing to
say that about a lot of other forms of
philosophy as well if he were around
today and looking at contemporary
analytic philosophy that would actually
fit this bill as well because the
expectations are so low the horizons are
so low that you can't actually fit
anything really substantive and
interesting and historically based in it
and it tends to produce people who are
rather stingy and giving and you know
when they teach philosophy they often
turn people off from philosophy same
thing would go by the way for a lot of
continental philosophy tends to be just
oriented around critique or cultural
studies or things like that they've lost
a sense of the whole of the totality of
the whole business of philosophy so
there's there's one other thing that he
says in here that I think is important
since whoever seeks me ratification
which is what we're talking about here
and wants to shrouded and miss the
manifold variety of this is earthly
existence and of thought so Hegel is
saying that edification what it's
missing is the variety of experience
yeah a lot it's not doing justice to our
actual lived experience as human beings
and by the way part of our experience
includes being thinking beings and part
of that experience includes running into
thoughts that other people already
thought before you
and articulated and that are waiting
there like you know a bounty for you to
actually latch on to and start exploring
that's part of what's being left out by
this way of doing philosophy that have
low expectations and sort of stingy Ness
and giving that merely edifies without
doing real philosophy and he finishes
here by saying in order to pursue the
indeterminate enjoyment of this
indeterminate divinity they can look
where they like to find all this why
because they'll find ample opportunity
to dream up something for themselves so
if this is your model for philosophy
that is really just edification and then
it's going to be based on you know this
sort of lack on this side and a lack on
this side that reinforce each other why
do people like that well because it
leaves them free to dream to daydream
not to dream in the sense of you know
creative dreaming whether actually you
know sketching out what they're going to
do something that would actually be do
some justice to this incredible world
that we live in and these incredible
beings that we are but rather to do the
kind of hazy I just kind of like this
idea and I'm gonna I'm going to explore
it I'm going to ride my hobbyhorse the
whole sense of it it lends itself to any
sort of desire any sort of motif or
theme that one would like just so long
as one allows it to remain kind of hazy
and doesn't question it and doesn't
expect any rigor from it as soon as one
starts to do that it falls apart
that's why edification doesn't satisfy
because edification doesn't go far
enough
edification does not provide us with the
rigor that real philosophy ought to